[Music]
a sort of interesting fact is that while
today programming is viewed as a
extremely male-dominated field it was
totally the opposite at the dawn of
computing all programmers of a from the
very beginning were women and it was
because this job was seen as being
beneath men and sort of somehow in the
interceding 30 40 50 years that's
contendere dynamic has completely
shifted around but what we're seeing now
is that sometimes it's the implicit
biases that we have which are holding
back women and minorities from entering
the workforce and either as data
scientists or or as computer engineers
and software engineers and we've seen a
lot of research in this area that's
shown that there can be some implicit
biases that and how we judge people
once we know about their name from their
name their sort of their gender or their
race and what we do right when we assess
the people who we're going to be working
for us is we are completely blind to
these things we actually strip away the
name and we consider people's
applications we just look at how they
perform on a series of challenges that
we give them that really can try to test
their ability to be a data scientist and
test their understanding of these kind
of core fundamental mathematical and
programming concepts and when we do that
I think it actually becomes a much more
fair process and it actually can help
increase the number of women
underrepresented minorities in who sort
of make it through the screening process
just to give you one sort of quick
anecdote about this there's a famous
story about music auditions in the 1970s
where orchestras had a very very tiny
percentage of their members are there
their players there the people were
playing in the orchestra as women and
what happened is at some point they
decided to try to
break free from this and they were put
down a curtain between the performer
that is the auditioner and the judge
judging panel that was trying to
determine whether he should be allowed
to play for the new Orchestra and when
they did the results were night and day
there's a famous study that's up on the
National Bureau of Economic Research his
website published by two famous
researchers from Harvard talking about
this it's called orchestrating diversity
and it talks about how the results were
night and day difference that women the
fraction of women who made it past the
screening round shot up something like
seven fold between not having the
curtain down and having a curtain down
and it just goes to sort of show that at
this time there was an implicit bias
that women weren't really the kind of
caliber of musician that you needed to
be able to perform at a Carnegie Hall
right at these kind of top that's kind
of top level symphonic performance and
when you put down a curtain and you just
listened to them as opposed to being
able to see whether they were men a man
or a woman you then without that kind of
knowledge you suddenly were forced to
make judgments just based in the music
just based on their ability and you saw
that they the that you are much more
willing to let in women than before
[Music]